[Music]
you know we got a great show tonight
number Eric said the game of thrones
author george RR martin is joining us
tonight that said the hell was that
hello there Curtin okay I have a bad
feeling that this is gonna be stupid
look everybody it's Chewbacca Frodo
Spock and Dumbledore yeah what are you
guys doing here we are a delegation from
the High Council of nerds and we have
traveled long and far to find george RR
martin okay so you're the High Council
of nerds is that right that's right the
council has decided that Game of Thrones
is now worthy of inclusion in the grand
pantheon of nerd culture alongside such
franchises as the Harry Potter series
Star Trek Lord of the Rings Batman
like Batman why are you wearing a
Chewbacca outfit Star Wars was kicked
off the council years ago but I'm really
into cosplay I'm a big fan okay that's
great
anyway yeah Conan we've come to welcome
george RR martin into the High Council
of nerds and bring him tribute okay what
kind of tribute are you bringing to
george RR martin we are bringing him a
tribute to fitting a true nerd mountain
Dew and cheeto no way we can find him
find him yeah you can find him in the
green room backstage Thank You Cohen
you're proven to be a great Ally to the
nerds
oh stop using the creepy voice we all
know you're Bruce Wayne I really don't
think it's that obvious it's on
Wikipedia douche bag
let's go plan down ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen get it up give it
up for four grown men you have children